adam finn we're seeing rising infection
numbers but hospitalizations aren't
keeping
pace uh
does it really matter if we hit 100 000
or 50 000 or whatever it is
of infections if the hospitalizations
aren't rising
uh but unfortunately they are rising and
and so the numbers of deaths and and
they will go up as the number of cases
go up because the virus will reach
people who are vulnerable and who may
get seriously ill so i think you know we
we can't uh be complacent about this
that this is a worsening situation
in an nhs which is all already under
enormous pressure
we are hearing a great deal about waning
immunity how serious a problem do you
think that is
uh i think it exists uh i think we are
seeing uh an increased risk particularly
amongst older people who were immunized
the longest time ago at the beginning of
the year
with an increasing risk that they may be
hospitalized actually they're still
relatively well protected but of course
there are large numbers of people and
with very high levels of spread of the
virus they are beginning to
show up in hospital the biggest risk of
course is amongst those who have not
been vaccinated at all including younger
adults not just older people who may who
may get sick and many of the
hospitalized people we're seeing at the
moment are in fact
immunized people
so the for you the the issue is still
getting everybody jabbed
uh i think that the the vaccine program
is doing a lot to make the situation
much less severe than it would otherwise
be and the vaccines principally are very
effective at stopping people from
getting seriously ill
they're not so effective unfortunately
at stopping infections altogether
or stopping the virus from being spread
about they do have an effect on that
but they're not by themselves going to
be enough at the present time to keep to
keep the spread of the virus under
control and we do need to see people
continuing to make efforts to avoid
contact to avoid transmission
and to do other things as well as get
vaccinated if we're going to stop this
rise from going up further
let's just clarify one thing about the
vaccination program the prime minister's
pinning pretty much all his hopes on
that success
um
do you think he is right
to float the idea of an extension of
booster program uh to under 50s
and by offering jobs at five months
rather than the current six months and
one week
i think we need to be careful that we
stick to the science here that
just giving more people vaccines
including people who maybe don't
actually need the vaccines yet
can could actually run the risk of
making things worse rather than better
if you boost people before they actually
need the vaccine it is in some sense as
a waste of vaccine but also it means
that you're immunizing them earlier and
they may make a smaller response to the
vaccine and that response may wear off
earlier
so i think the idea of just getting more
doses into indiscriminately into
people's arms is not really necessarily
going to solve the problem
i think we do need to focus particularly
on the most elderly people
and do this in a structured and
strategic way in order to have the
maximum impact
so to be clear you wouldn't
move to five months but you would focus
on vulnerable groups could you
elaborate on who you're thinking of
yeah certainly the the the strategy for
the booster program is somewhat similar
to the strategy first time around in
other words to start with the oldest
people first
and work our way down through the age
groups and at the same time focused on
people who are particularly high risk
who are younger so it really does mirror
what we did first time around
and we do need to do it in that order in
order to have the maximum impact as you
get younger and younger you're getting
to people who've got stronger and
stronger immune responses and who have
been immunized more and more recently
and so you get to a law of diminishing
returns to a point where you're really
not achieving anything at all you're
just using up your resources to boost
people who don't actually need boosters
at this time
but i would like to re-emphasize the
fact that the vaccine program by itself
in the current situation even if things
go optimally it is not in my opinion
enough to bring things under control we
do need to have people using lateral
flow tests
avoiding
contact with large numbers of people in
enclosed spaces using uh masks all of
those things now need to happen if we're
going to stop this rise and get things
under control soon enough to stop a real
meltdown in the middle of the winter
professor finn that sounds pretty
clearly like you think i know you're not
responsible for making policy but that
you think we should move to plan b
now
well some kind of plan b what i think we
should stop doing and i think we did
hear this from the secretary of state
from health last week is a recognition
uh that that giving the message to the
population that the pro the problem's
all over and that there's no need for
any further
restrictions or
efforts being made to reduce
transmission of infection is sending out
the wrong message um and i i worry in
fact that the vaccine program itself is
suffering as a consequence of this
suggestion that somehow the problem's
gone and we can all go back to normal
again because that will
increasingly
make people drunk to the conclusion that
they've not been vaccinated there's no
real need to do it
so i do think we need to see a very
different kind of message coming from
the government now that there is a
serious problem and we all need to
continue to contribute to reducing
transmission so that we can get through
the winter and the and the nhs can stay
afloat and absolutely we can avoid
lockdowns and the disasters that those
bring we all want to avoid that but we
can't avoid it if we all just go back to
normal now
and would a clear way of sending that
message be
to reimpose some restrictions
mask wearing for example
uh
staying away from workplaces for example
well as you said it's not my job to
create policy i think this needs to be
brought about whether it can be brought
about by clear messaging and
communication i think the british public
are
for by and large a pretty responsible
lot and if you give them a clear message
of what you want them to do they will
they will pay attention to that
whether it's that sufficient or whether
it actually needs to be done by
compelling people i think that is a
decision for the politicians but one way
or another we do need to bring about a
situation where there is less
transmission of virus going on in in the
community and we can't just rely on the
vaccine program to achieve that
can i ask a a a broader question are you
more worried at the moment about
unvaccinated
individuals
or about resurgence of covid
or about the
problem of conventional flu given that
there's less certainty this year about
the efficacy of the flu vaccine
uh well i don't see those things as uh
alternatives i think they're all true um
so i i'm particularly worried about the
number of adults that have not been
vaccinated uh i'm perplexed that there
are so many such people because they are
a very important group when it comes to
uh the the number of serious illnesses
we're seeing the pressure on the
hospitals and of course they are all
personally at great risk of serious
illness and even death so those are
people that i think we really do need to
be concerned about
and we need to focus on the communities
where coverage is low
and do everything we can to make vaccine
readily available and to make clear
information available to people so they
can make the sensible decision to get
immunized
i do think we're seeing covid cases
rising at the moment not so rapidly in
terms of severe cases as before but of
course in terms of cases overall very
large numbers and i'm very concerned
about flu this year as is as is everyone
else because we had no flu last year to
speak of the population is more
susceptible to flu
and that on top of everything else now
we're mixing together
could really significantly add to the
pressure on the health service so the
flu vaccine just kicking off is really
important too